Lee Byung-chul, the founder of Samsung, explained
that the Korean Hanja of the word, Samsung,
means “Three Stars”.
The stars signified something that was eternal,
while three was symbolic for “big, numerous
and powerful”.
That is precisely the feeling you’ll get
when you take a tour of their headquarters
called the Samsung Digital City located in
Suwon, just thirty kilometres south of Seoul
- South Korea’s capital.
In fact, the multinational tech giant has
several buildings and developments in other
nearby cities like Yongin and Hwasung.
Together, the space occupied by Samsung in
these three regions is referred to as Samsung
Digital Valley.
Our tour of the city revealed to us a similar
work ethic like that of Silicon Valley, however,
the level of care afforded to employees in
the digital city is perhaps rivalled by no
other company, and the effect of Samsung’s
presence to the locals is also a highly positive
relationship.
Welcome back to our channel!
If you haven’t already, make sure you hit
the subscribe button and ring that bell, so
you’re notified every time we upload a new
video!
Now, you probably know Samsung as one of the
most recognizable and top cellphone manufacturers.
And over the years, they have proven to have
earned that status through many of their sleek
designs and innovations in the mobile phone
industry (go through several short clips of
Samsung Phone designs throughout this sentence).
While some of their products have just straight
up been the bomb (clip of Samsung Note 7 exploding
0:27 to 0:28).
However, Samsung is much more than that.
Samsung electronics may be the largest information
technology and consumer electronics maker
by revenue, but other large affiliates exist
too.
For instance, Samsung Heavy is the second
largest shipbuilding company, Samsung Engineering
and Samsung C&T Corporation are two of the
largest construction companies worldwide,
while Samsung Life Insurance is the fourteenth
largest insurance company in the world.
So you can understand when the office space
in Samsung’s Suwon headquarters alone covers
three hundred and ninety acres; almost four
times as large as the Vatican and similar
in area to Monaco.
Samsung Digital City is located in Suwon,
which is the last completely walled city in
the country.
The wall is a UNESCO heritage site, and as
a tourist attraction, it is the other reason
besides the presence of Samsung in the city,
that draws so many foreigners to Suwon.
During the Korean war, Samsung facilities
in Seoul were so damaged that the Samsung
founder, Lee Byung-chul, had to move from
the capital city to Suwon in 1951.
By 1969, the company would diversify its interests
so Samsung Electronics could be born and it’s
headquarters, naturally, was fixed within
the walls of the city that saved it from destruction.
Eventually, with the growth of Samsung, the
arrival of other subsidiaries and departments,
and the effect of the companies on the lives
and employment of people in the city, Samsung
Digital City has evolved to accommodate the
explosive economic metamorphosis.
In fact, two other cities now also house semiconductor
factories for Samsung Electronics - Samsung
Nano City in Yongin, and Samsung Nano City
in Hwasung.
Both cities are just a few kilometers from
Suwon and they reflect the fact that Samsung
really has spread out its roots in South Korea
like a tree from a little seed.
Now, in Samsung Digital City, there are about
thirty-five thousand employees, four landmark
towers, over a hundred and thirty buildings
that include labs, offices, recreational facilities,
a guesthouse for visiting researchers, and
other facilities in the city that cater to
the large workforce.
One of my favourites is the availability of
over a hundred and fifty teachers looking
after the children of some of the employees.
Because if you have thirty-five thousand people
in a large area, unless those thirty-five
thousand people are these guys (clip of The
Unsullied from Game of Thrones), chances are
that they have children amongst them.
That’s a very important step they’ve made,
just like the resting rooms for employees
with special treatments for pregnant women.
Life is meant to be easy, and work is part
of life, so it’s great to see that you can
easily transport yourself to a hundred and
three different destinations on any of the
five hundred shuttle buses in Samsung Digital
City.
But what does work look like in this place?
Well, there's a MIMO Chamber where Galaxy
phones are tested.
The MIMO, or Multiple-Input and Multiple-Output
Chamber is where radio links like 4G LTE are
experimented on.
Speaking of connectivity and experimentation,
the most feared internet connectivity, 5G,
has it's own testing space called 5G city.
In 5G city, Samsung workers experiment on
how to get the technology up and running for
the things it would be useful for like the
internet of things or IoT.
IoT will create interconnected objects that
will be able to exchange data wirelessly and
do awesome stuff like; your fridge and smartwatch
conspiring to advise you from eating late
at night and save your life.
What a diabolical and despicable technology!
(Chuckle)
There’s also the anechoic chamber which
works to get the best conditions for the audio
tests of Samsung electronics.
It does this by absorbing both sound and electromagnetic
waves, thus eliminating every form of reverberation
or echo and simulating an infinitely large
room.
The name “an-echoic” (emphasize both parts
separated by the hyphen in “an-echoic”)
is derived from the fact that the room lacks
any echo.
And you wouldn’t believe the amount of work
that went into the sounds for Samsung electronics.
Because there’s a whole team of music artists
and producers working daily in the company’s
Sound Lab to develop even the tiniest of sounds
that you get from a Samsung device.
The voicing of Bixby - Samsung’s virtual
assistant, your chat notification, the sound
of your air conditioner turning off, the sounds
from your smart TV, name it!
These guys have got it covered (clip of people
in the Sound Lab).
The Digital City also has the Samsung Innovation
Museum where you can time travel (clip of
Loki disappearing with the Tesseract) through
the rich history of innovation at the company
since its inception in 1938.
And there are also older objects from two
hundred and seventy years ago that will inspire
anyone looking at them as they basically tell
the story of human ingenuity.
This is the kind of inspiring environment
that the employees work in, and there’s
more.
Employees have access to free healthcare services
like flu shots, dental treatment, physicals,
and traditional acupuncture.
It get's even more healthy as employees can
engage in a variety of sports with the availability
of many sporting facilities like the ten basketball
courts, four badminton courts, two baseball
diamonds, three soccer fields and an Olympic-sized
swimming pool.
There are also over six hundred and fifty
employee clubs where workers indulge in once-in-a-lifetime
fantasies like paragliding or regular hobbies
like photography.
There are also many events from rock concerts
or a string quartet that you’ll bump into
every now and then in the City’s many open
spaces.
The most loved event is Family Day where the
entire Samsung Digital City gets turned into
a theme park and employees even ride around
in go-karts and have fun with their friends
and families.
I’d be tempted to say that Family Day is
the ultimate inspiration, but that would be
food, and Samsung knows this as well.
That’s why they have a four thousand-seater
cafeteria with almost a hundred different
delicacies on its menu.
The company serves over seventy-two thousand
meals over the course of breakfast, lunch,
and dinner.
And the food is the biggest inspiration not
just because it fills the bellies of the employees,
it also fills the bellies of the locals living
around the towns of Suwon, Yongin, and Hwasung.
You see, serving seventy-two thousand meals
every day creates a large demand for foodstuff
which the local farmers are more than willing
to supply.
This is part of a long history of the company's
positive influence on the country.
Take for instance, the fact that Samsung is
considered as the major driving force behind
the country's economic resurgence also called
the "Miracle of Han River".
Samsung and it's affiliate companies are responsible
for a fifth of South Korea's exports, and
the company's revenues has been estimated
to be about seventeen percent of the country's
total GDP.
Samsung C&T has a major hand in South Urban
development, building over two hundred thousand
houses in the country since the eighties.
The importance of the company's presence in
the country cannot be overstated but it can
be summed in the way that a Washington Post
headline once put it, "In South Korea, the
Republic of Samsung".
But we all know it goes beyond the borders
of the "Land of the Morning Calm".
Samsung is immense, and we can see how their
attention to giving their workers the best
in their Digital City and Digital Valley has
driven innovation and a brilliant work ethic
that has helped them take over several sectors
of industry in the world.
I personally like Samsung's Headquarters not
just because it's awesome, but also because
any apple you'll see (picture of an apple)
here are healthy, and the windows here (picture
of office windows) are transparent.
What do you think of this Digital City?
Where would you prefer to work than here?
Also, do you think Tesla's new Starbase city
will give it a run for its money (pop-up of
our video on how Tesla builds rockets in a
week)?
Let us know in the comments below.
And if you enjoyed this video, make sure to
give it a like!
And check out more awesome ones on the Simply
Tech channel.
Thanks for watching, and we'll see you next
time!